ce je vous présente le nouveau view 2 go
de wick au truc un petit peu sympa grâce
à la réalité augmentée et à la télé jans
artificielle comme une perte de temps du
kop le marbre
vous pouvez rajouter voilà des filles
des petits trucs un peu marre en voilà
et bon appétit bien sûr j'espère que ça
vous plaira
alors là franchement je vous cache pas
que j'ai l'air un peu ridicules mais bon
c'est la passion du métier c'est assez
sympa
[Musique]
voilà aujourd'hui on parle de ricoh
alors aujourd'hui sa nappe est comme
d'habitude je parle vachement de
smartphones qui sont faits pour de la
performance qui sont des smartphones
puissants le nouveau smartphone qui est
bon pour la photo le nouveau smartphone
qui est optimisé pour la vidéo le
nouveau smartphone qui fait si qui fait
ça qui fait la vaisselle qui fait à
manger qui fait leur passage voilà
aujourd'hui pas du tout
aujourd'hui on va être sur un smartphone
d'entrée de gamme un smartphone je
dirais plus modestes un smartphone qui
s'adresse aux primo accédants les primo
accédants c'est les personnes qui vont
acheter un smartphone pour la première
fois et sport notamment un public plus
jeune donc en règle générale ce sont vos
parents qui vont vous achetez votre
smartphone
et c'est justement aujourd'hui l'idée de
cette vidéo on va parler de ricoh parce
qu'un truc que je vous montrais et qui
est vraiment intéressant
on va donc parler aujourd'hui du view de
godo ico et d'ici quelques jours on va
parler vieux de plus de week ou alors je
sais pas si vous opérez il ya le view de
view 2go view de plus view de pro ya une
gamme qui est hyper complète et qui peut
paraître un peu complexes comme ça donc
ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va acheter
un petit coup d'oeil à la gamme déjà
pour comprendre les grossir là on est
sur la gamme de 1,8 cette année cette
hyper hyper simple tout ça ce sont
vraiment les smartphones d'entrée de
gamme et tout ça va pas trop s'attarder
dessus
nous on va s'intéresser à partir du view
2 go ces smartphones qu'on regarde
aujourd'hui le plus haut de gamme dans
l'entrée de gamme c'est le vieux de pro
qu'on a déjà testé ya quelques temps on
va tester d'ici quelques jours le vieux
de plus ce qui est juste là pour
l'instant on regarde le vieux 2 go qui
est juste là donc voilà un peu pour
comprendre la gamme de huy cote cette
année
donc aujourd'hui on vraiment se
concentrer sur le view 2 go qui est
juste là alors vous allez voir le
smartphone n'est pas complètement fou
c'est pas un smartphone hallucinant avec
des perfs de dingue
bien au contraire ça smartphone assez
modeste un smartphone d'entrée de gamme
mais qui par contre a vraiment des
points intéressants pour tous ceux qui
veulent en premier smartphone il est
franchement pas mal oui qu fait vraiment
vos efforts sur ce smartphone il ya
plein de petits points de détails qui
sont assez marrant donc on va le détail
est tout de suite si vous voulez voir le
unboxing de ce produit je vous invite à
me rejoindre sur ma chaîne ait d'itv sur
instagram
c'est là où je vais faire le nom boxing
comme ça vous en saurez plus à ce moment
là ça sera plutôt cool déjà d'un point
de vue purement technique ce qui est
vraiment bien avec ce produit qui coûte
159 euros on peut le trouver d'ailleurs
beaucoup moins cher aux alentours des je
crois 139 euros je vous ai mis un lien
dans la description ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que la gamme view 2-2 chez ou
lycos sont des écrans 19/9 là vous avez
un écran de 5,93 pousse donc qui est
quand même relativement grand la
définition est pas complètement dingue
1512 par 720 pixels c'est donc du 720p
on est donc sur du hd on n'est pas sur
un écran full hd
de l'autre côté dans cette gamme de
tarifs on va pas trop trop lui en
demander c'est une dalle ipc du lcd vous
avez 282 ttp enfin voilà bon c'est un
truc qui marche bien c'est pas que le
plus dingue du monde mais ça fonctionne
pour regarder des vidéos où l'expérience
est franchement pas mal
vous allez zou mais vous allez y avoir
un petit crop au niveau de l'encolure à
vous le voyez il ya une grande barre
noire sur le sur le côté droit bon
forcément on est sur un smartphone qui
coûtent pas hyper cher en termes de
techno l'écran ne descend pas jusqu'en
bas mais bon fils a fait la faire pour
moi ça ne pose absolument aucun problème
l'encoche ne me dérange pas les gens qui
n'aiment pas le reproche qui toute façon
ne l'aimons pas là dessus
voilà pour moi ça me pose pas de soucis
alors effectivement la qualité n'est pas
complètement dingue on est forcément sur
un smartphone pas très cher on va pas
trop leur demander
par contre ce qui est cool c'est que le
som marche pas trop mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
haut-parleurs mono qui se situe juste là
à l'arrière par contre ce qui est cool
c'est que là vous avez une toute petite
bille je sais pas si vous la voyez bien
la petite bille elle sert en fin de
compte a levé le smartphone quand vous
allez le poser à plat comme ça l'idée
c'est que vous ayez toujours du som
parce que ça ne va pas plaquer le
téléphone donc vous allez vraiment
pouvoir profiter de votre sont même en
ce téléphone est posée et ça c'est
plutôt pas mal
parce qu'en règle générale et haut
parleurs situés en dessous là c'est pas
le cas il situe à l'arrière donc voilà
forcément il fallait trouver une petite
astuce le fait d'avoir mis cette petite
vie c'est assez astucieux puisqu'on est
dans la partie audio il faut aussi
savoir que ici on a une petite prise
jack
ce qui vous permet effectivement on m'a
de pouvoir brancher votre petit casse
avec la prise jack les gens qui ont des
portes ouvertes mais ça vaut quand même
le coup de le dire et c'est pas mal
parce que en plus c'est vraiment un bel
effort qui est fait je trouve là dessus
sur ce qui peut loger smartphones
maintenant voyons voir la qualité audio
ça fonctionne la qualité est franchement
correct c'est pas là où on va avoir le
plus de volume sonore
donc là effectivement ici il n'ya pas de
bruit j'imagine que dans un
environnement bruyant ça va être quand
même moins confort bon l'idée c'est
pendant plus de se flinguer les oreilles
je vous dirai dans l'absolu 30 un casque
à réduction de bruit d'un côté mais de
300 euros dans un casque pour brancher
sur un smartphone qui coûte 140 150
euros nous devons pas trop la logique
donc bon pour écouter chez vous ça me
paraît plutôt pas mal au casque mais
d'alors vous avez un environnement qui
est vraiment très bruyant vous risquez
d'être un petit peu limité là dessus à
côté de ça je pense que nico a plutôt
bien réussi sa copie parce que sortir un
smartphone avec un écran de cette taille
à ce prix là c'est quand même bien alors
après en terme de perfs s'est pas
complètement ouf je vous ai fait un test
sur en tout vous avez un score de 59
1532 franchement c'est pas
extraordinaire d'un côté de purement
technique on à l'intérieur un qualcomm
snapdragon 430 cadencé jusqu'à 1,4
gigahertz au maximum 3 giga de ram 32
gigas de stockage extensible c'est pas
fou fou côté j'ai pu c'est une adreno
505 ça marche les pertes sont pas dingue
faut pas trop lui en demander
par contre pour un usage quotidien je
dirais de la photo de la vidéo quelques
petits jeux ça fait la sphère voyez
techniquement lâche en train de jouer à
ce fait ni trop ça fonctionne très bien
jeu est cool alors voilà faut pas lui
mettre des jeux trop gourmand vous allez
oublier des fortes night vous avez
oublié dpu bg vous allez oublier des
choses comme ça mais pour un jeu un
petit peu stoner a pour s'amuser ça
marchera extrêmement dire pour moi ce
smartphone est vraiment excellent pour
naviguer sur instagram pour regarder vos
photos tout ce que vous voulez partager
c'est vraiment bien et d'ailleurs c'est
justement ça qui est cool là dessus
c'est la partie photo vidéo comme je le
disais on n'est pas du tout sur un
smartphone hyper puissant en termes de
vidéos et de photos
c'est exactement la même chose vous avez
à l'arrière ici un capteur simple de 12
mégapixels en dessous c'est un flash
on va pas lui demander la lune par
contre ce qui est cool c'est le travail
qui est fait derrière on a d'un point de
vue logiciel par rico ça c'est plutôt
intéressant à l'avant aussi s'est pas
complètement fou vous avez une caméra de
5 mégapixels le rendu est pas d'un go je
vous montre ce que ça donne en terme de
photos vidéos et après de vous montrer
ce qu'on peut faire
d'un point de vue logiciel et vous allez
voir que wilko a plutôt bien réussi sa
copie là dessus là je teste la caméra de
cette fille en pleine lumière on voit ce
que ça dit un petit peu la lumière
j'aime bien cet effet assez sympathique
ça va on me voit pas trop mal vous me
direz vous ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire donc là maintenant on va
tester non elliott tu ne viens pas sur
la vidéo
je ne veux pas te montrer à cinq ans je
veux pas que tout le monde te vois en
vidéo donc non donc ça c'était la caméra
de celle-ci maintenant regarder la
caméra alors landais sans les caméras
arrière donc c'est elliott qui filent
qu'à cinq ans bougez pas j'aime quand je
te fais le chef c'est à dire à ton âme
et sans envie sans moi voilà est-ce que
tu tiens voix arrête de bouger neigeux
ont tendance à les tester cet homme
derrière danse organise avec mon
assistant est encore un peu petit donc
voilà je ne touche pas je ne fais pas la
chaîne hbo y est ce que c'est bien elle
paraît bien voyez les flous pas fait
faillite ou c'est pas normal
le téléphone retour sur la caméra avant
papa il était pas floues en réalité
eliota tu dis n'importe quoi j'étais pas
du tout flou non j'ai des peuples ou non
ce qui marche quand même pas mal
l'appareil photo gr ouais d'accord
yves lebahy bas en termes de photos ce
qui est plutôt bien réussi là dessus
c'est le détourage au niveau du mode
portrait grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle parce que normalement
l'intelligence artificielle vous
reconnaît un visage et vous détour au
niveau du visage mais ce qui est plutôt
bien réussi là dessus c'est qu'il va
reconnaître tout le personnage et même
vous des tours et les mains aux
alentours donc vous avez un personnage
qui complètement bien des tours et et ça
croyez moi tous les smartphones
par ce soit avec une main avec demain là
effectivement entre les doigts il a un
petit peu de mal pour finir le détourage
mais sinon ça fonctionne quand même pas
mal là j'ai mis un flou à 60 76 % je
crois et ça marche aussi bien entre les
doigts là ça n'a pas mis le flou ici
dans l'espace par contre dans l'espace
la salle amis ça m'a fait un petit peu
mon doigt un peu fou bon c'est pas non
plus complètement dingue on est sur un
smartphone qui coupent pas non plus
hyper cher voyelles pouces il est un
petit peu c'est un peu mal shooté mais
je trouve qu'en tout cas ce qui est bien
sûr un smartphone de ce prix là d'entrée
de gamme on arrive quand même à réaliser
des choses qui d'un point de vue
technique sont plutôt bien ça c'est un
point positif et il faut le souligner
côté photo vidéo c'est un grand standard
vous avez la photo vous avez la vidéo
vous avez ici tous les filtres en
réalité augmentée qui sont la
reconnaissance des visages
je vous présente le nouveau view 2 go de
huy qu un mode un petit peu saurais pas
vous dire un truc un petit peu sympa
grâce à la réalité augmentée et à la
belligérance artificielle avec un
intérieur artificielle on peut quand
même faire de temps du kop le marbre
vous pouvez rajouter voilà des petits
des petits trucs un peu marrant histoire
de rigoler un peu voilà est bon appétit
bien sûr j'espère que ça vous plaira
voilà donc ça c'est un peu ce qui est
cool avec le we go vieux de go c'est
effectivement bon l'intelligence
artificielle la réalité augmentée qui se
mélangent alors là franchement je ne
cache pas que j'ai l'air un peu
ridicules mais bon c'est la passion du
métier c'est comme ça donc tout mais je
trouve que cette coupe est plutôt bien
réussi sur ce smartphone parce que pas
mal de petites options du point de vue
de l'appareil photo c'est assez sympa
vous avez également ici le mode portrait
avec votre flux vous pouvez régler et
ici le mode embellissement vous
choisissez votre peau si elle plus ou
moins lisse
voilà un grand classique mais ça marche
très bien le vieux 2go tourne sous
android
8.1 vous avez du bluetooth 4 points 2
vous avez une double lecteur de carte
sim 32 gigas de stockage que vous pouvez
augmenter ce que vous voulez rajouter un
petit peu plus de musique un peu de
vidéo tout ce que vous voulez dans même
de la faute vient pointer aussi coup là
dedans c'est l'autonomie vous avez une
batterie énorme de 4000 militants paire
eur alors 3 sachant que derrière vous
avez un écran qui ne consomme pas
particulièrement
vous avez un seau qui ne consomment pas
particulièrement donc si vous n'êtes pas
toute la journée dessus vous allez
pouvoir le garder une journée sans aucun
problème ça c'est aussi un point
extrêmement positif sur ce smartphone
alors la question maintenant c'est qui
va acheter ce smartphone acquise des
styles destine aux primo accédants là
dessus pour moi vous êtes sur un
smartphone qui va être achetée par des
parents pour leurs enfants pour leurs
adolescents en tout cas c'est un petit
peu ça l'idée mon avis parce que on est
sur un produit qui a quand même de très
belle qualité si on veut monter un petit
peu plus en gamme là dessus on va se
diriger sur le view de plus ce qui est
là
si l'on ne voit parader ces quelques
jours il a un double module photo à
l'arrière il a un capteur d'empreintes
digitales
la d3 petit truc en plus par rapport à
celui ci un peu plus d'aura enfin voilà
ça je voulais théret d'ici quelques
jours
mais je trouve que pour commencer pour
arriver sur un premier smartphone celui
ci me paraît plutôt pas mal parce que ce
qu'on va faire avec
en réalité c'est des petits jeux des
réseaux sociaux
quelques photos tout ça sans prétention
parce qu'on n'a pas une qualité dan
derrière ça fonctionne c'est correct
c'est propre ça marche bien
voilà peu pour ce week au lieu de go à
noter que vous avez une recharge ici
avec du micro usb bon le bouton de
volume pour le monte 17 sont le bouton
pour l'allumer prétendre qu'il feint pas
là dessus est ce que oui quoi bien
réussi c'est que là vous avez un bouton
qui s'accrochent sous le doigt là les
boutons volume d'accrochages entre élise
ont pensé tout de suite sur tel bouton a
mené au touché et ça c'est aussi bien
réussi et c'est plein de petits détails
entre cette partie là qui accroche entre
la petite bille ici à l'arrière vario
par là je trouve que ricco a bien bossé
son vieux 2 go et pour voir qu'on est
sur un smartphone du tout franchement
pas cher il a plein de petits éléments
comme ça qui mis bout à bout bas fond ce
smartphone à smartphone assez séduisant
d'ailleurs dites moi ce que vous en
pensez
comment vous trouvez ce vieux 2 go est
ce que vous pourriez vous laisser tenter
ce que vous avez déjà un smartphone de
huy qu un view go 1 view de pro
un view 2 voilà j'ai pas y'a plein de
smartphones dans la gamme donc dites moi
comment vous le trouvez est ce que vous
aimez aussi ce petit d'aubry y ont fait
ça fait son effet c'est assez sympa vous
marquez tout ça en commentaire je vous
invite bien évidemment vous abonner à
rester connectés parce qu'on va parler
de plein d'autres smartphones y ait une
vraie grosse actu derrière on va parler
d'ordinateurs par les deux mondes
connectés on va parler de tablettes
entendre parler de plein de choses et
puis on va tester d'ici quelques jours
le view de plus toujours de l'ico comme
ça on pourra se faire une idée un peu
complète de la guerre wiko pour cette
année voilà vous marquez tout savourer
c'est ça je vous embrasse et à bientôt
[Musique]